uh okay let's see
um why don't we go next there's there's
just so many people
itching to get on i guess is the way i
would say it
um and we wanna you know take a tour of
different
areas for sure let's go to i i hope i'm
saying this correctly is it
sorelle from texas or sarrell
hi david can you hear me yes i can what
what is the origin of that name
what a pleasure it is a combination of
my first and second name
oh okay very nice how are you today
good good but i've been following for a
while and i recently uh
subscribed as well so i thoroughly enjoy
the
contents and i want to thank you for
that thank you
basically i just wanted to make a a
comment
on the importance of education
and not only institutionalized education
but what we're seeing at
home i feel like the the situation right
now in the u.s
um i live on the border so i also get a
taste of
mexico and what's going on over there
and all the border issues but
as an educator myself i see this as a
reflection of many years of of neglect
in in awareness and social awareness
right our students right now
have this this sense of um detachment
from the political reality and i feel
like
we you've talked about it a lot recently
so the problem is what do we do with all
these people that
who voted for trump and who who are
um champion champions of
of of these attitudes that cause us so
much
grief and and social um you know
destruction
so in a way i just want to make kind of
like a call of the about the importance
of of
making this awareness from home and
starting also
at home because these people are going
to vote in a few years and this is the
circus so governments come and go
but later on you know we're going to
have to vote again and what are the
choices if we tolerate
all these all these um attitudes if we
normalize
right well that was going to be my
question to you which is
by the time you're as an educator by the
time they get to you
is it too late like it really depends on
starting at home
um that's a great question i teach high
school
and and college survey courses yeah so
this
kind of that right time where um
youth um they're distracted with other
things
right and developing a character
but you see the behavior and the
classroom and sometimes
it is this is um microscopic vision of
what we see
in society right right the intolerance
the rudeness the things that inherently
come from home
and and these are values that have
nothing to do with religion that have
nothing to do
with anything but plain moral and being
a good person
well that seems like a big hill to climb
i i i i think you're completely right
but this is a big task
right and that's why i also think that
sometimes governments um
do not invest enough in education
because it's a long-term investment
yeah if your term is two four or six
years why are you going to
tie up a whole bunch of money and things
you'll never see the benefits of as a
politician
right right does that
and thank you so much for the work keep
it up and it's
it's great talking to you thank you so
much really a pleasure
uh let's take a quick break if you're
holding on to talk to me don't go
anywhere
because we're going right back to the
calls after this short break
privacy.com is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you five dollars
just for using their free service at
privacy.com
pacman privacy is a service i've been
using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number in your web browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want
i especially love it for free trials
where you need to give a credit card
number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
slash pacman